estelle youssoufa bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france la situation est hors de contrôle
depuis déjà un certain temps à mayotte
qui prend de plein fouet une nouvelle
fac une nouvelle vague de contaminations
quel est précisément la situation à sur
place alors en fait nous pour nous
l'arrivée de secours c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce que mayotte en a besoin
mais il faut quand même comprendre que
c'est une solution temporaire et que
mayotte reste un désert médical donc
aller la solution à long terme
c'est ces secours c'est 35 soignants qui
ont été envoyées vont repartir et nous
on va rester avec une situation qui est
grave on paye des décennies de mauvaise
santé publique politique de santé
publique à mayotte et il faut absolument
que la rs de mayotte qui est dirigée par
dominique voynet revoit sa copie
il faut absolument qu'on développe la
formation des soignants mahorais qu'on
développe la télémédecine pour sortir
mayotte de cet isolement
parce que votre reporter l'a dit il ya
seize lits de réanimation pour en fait
450 mille habitants sur l'idh
c'est vraiment pas assez on est avec une
situation où toutes les pathologies
normal les spécialités classique
n'existe pas à mayotte et donc on est
très dépendant de la télémédecine et on
attend beaucoup de la rs de mayotte que
deux voix n'est qui la dirige
investissent pour qu'on ait une santé
local parce qu'on peut pas continuer à
voir à mayotte
notre population qui meurent ainsi
justement cette épidémie a révélé
peut-être l'un des problèmes majeurs de
delisle est ce qu'on vaut aujourd'hui on
peut parler de désert médical pourquoi
alors en fait on n'a qu'un seul hôpital
à mayotte et aujourd'hui il est
complètement saturé les autorités ont
réussi à monter à plus d'une trentaine
de lits de réanimation en bricolant en
faisant le maximum avec ce qu'il ya sur
place et tous les jours ma
autant voient en moyenne quatre patients
pour être en réanimation à l'île de la
réunion mais la réunion a aussi
maintenant le variant sud africain et ça
va être difficile pour la réunion
d'accueillir ces patients et ça pose un
gros problème pas mais pour mayotte
parce qu'on n'est pas sorti du mur
épidémique dans lequel en est et qu'est
ce qu'on va faire de nos patientes donc
on est très inquiet pour les semaines
qui viennent nous au collectif des
citoyens de mayotte on appelle les
autorités à envoyer un navire hôpital de
la marine nationale pour soulager notre
hôpital et pour que nos passions n'est
pas à aller en métropole parce que c'est
une opération avec un pont aérien
sanitaire entre mayotte et la métropole
c'est une opération qui est très
compliqué ça veut dire au moins 17
heures de voyage pour les patients qui
sont dans un état grave
donc c'est très risqué mais je voulais
quand même attiré l'attention et
profitez de votre antenne pour lancer un
appel par rapport à mayotte
notre il vit un traumatisme en a une
population qui est vraiment dans une
grande détresse toutes les familles sont
touchées et on entend un discours de la
part des autorités qui est inhumain qui
culpabilise la population 1 voit la
préfecture qui fait le tri entre les
pauvres et qui décide de ne pas donner
la d'alimentaire pour les mains en
résine mahorais nous ce dont on a besoin
c'est aussi de compassion et qu'on sorte
de ce discours qui culpabilise les
marais et les mahoraises et c'est grâce
à vous dans les médias en métropole
qu'on arrive à obtenir des cheveux
courts et sa sauce de lévis on sait que
lille connaît un confinement généralisée
depuis le 5 février des mesures qui
arrive à chaque fois trop tardivement
selon vous va écouter l'alertent de l'
oms elle a été lancée fin décembre le
confinement il a été seulement annoncé
début février on a perdu des semaines
précieuse et on a entendu dans la bouche
des autorités un discours nous disant il
ne faut pas confiné parce qu'il faut
protéger l'économie informelle ce sont
les les les périphrases des autorités
pour ne pas parler d'économie
clandestine un tiers de la population
sont des clans des stars mais vous savez
toutes ces mesures sanitaires tant qu'on
laisse les frontières ouvertes tant que
les kwassa kwassa arrive chargé du
comorien en situation irrégulière qui
sont
malade on n'arrivera pas à sortir
mayotte de la crise dans laquelle on est
parce qu aujourd'hui mayotte est une île
pestiférés on ne peut plus sortir de
mayotte sans des motifs qui sont
examinées six jours en amont par la
préfecture
on a entendu des personnes qui ont des
motifs impérieux officiels qui sont
quand même refoulé à l'aéroport des
malades des personnes qui ont des
attestations médicales qui ont des qui
habitent en dehors de mayotte et qui
n'arrive pas à quitter l'île parce que
on est en train de verrouiller mayotte
donc la situation tant que les autorités
sont toujours avec trois temps un train
de retard on va continuer à tomber comme
des mouches
et l'hécatombe va continuer merci
beaucoup en tout cas s el youssoufia
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président du collectif des citoyens de
mayotte